Hey  so what are we going to do with  ourselves with some and iris  we have an entire someone who can do  whatever an iris  yeah she just thought she wants to have  dinner that existed nice dinner you know  she wearing a very small skirt into the  very really long shower nice  I still wake up thinking she's here and  use a serious problem  it would just be 1% more human we would  all drown but that's not nice you care  what I've been up to at all you need to  leave talk to you and when your heart is  open it's uh nope really to hit hate you  at least I know it's not love you know  my performance with all the parts and  you keep walking and try not to fall  down for as long as possible  you  [Music]  you